[Music]
I'm not here as your ex I really do want
to buy a car you know they cost money
and I have some well then come right in
on Affairs awkwardly reunites with her
acts on moms 100th episode airing
tonight ET online Leeanne Aguilera was
just with oughta and Allison Janney
whose relationship is less
mother-daughter and more like tight fit
sisters
oh yeah girl she's just one of my
favorite souls on this planet the love
between Anna and Allison was in full
display on the party's red carpet I
enjoy her I know I do because I'm always
knocking on your justinian door I'm like
Allison come out and play with me
they've been playing the often
dysfunctional mother-daughter duo for
five seasons take me back to the first
time that you shared a scene with
Allison she took my arm and she said I
know we are destined to be friends okay
that's it you're getting a hug and she
had just given birth to Jack and I just
loved her immediately we were on the mom
set back then a month before the series
debut I don't know what I'm doing
awesome mom and I'm the show I don't
know what I'm doing as a mom either so I
guess we have that in common
jack on a son with her ex Chris Pratt is
now five years old what's the latest
cute thing he's done this morning he
said mom you're a dragon can you breathe
fire we're so lucky that's such a
brilliant wonderful boy and I hope that
as he goes through being a child in this
crazy world that he's happy what do you
say to you that's what listen they say
that they say old they're older now
though they say things that are shocking
me every day good work all right back to
Allison Janney she of course is the
Oscar frontrunner for Best Supporting
Actress for I Tania and if she wins
guess where she will be the day after
she won't be celebrating like she's
never celebrated before am i right I
think that but she's also she told us
she's gonna be back on the set of my
tour to work gonna be a party for on
that set for sure